hello chess fans i'm sam copeland national master
on the content team here at chess.com and i'm here
today with another amazing computer chess game
this game was played in a bullet test tournament
between komodo and the chess engine scorpio
i'm going to go ahead and claim at the outset
of this video that this is the best chess
miniature that i have seen this century
in fact the game doesn't really feel like it's
from this century much less the 1900s it feels
like it's from the 1800s the era of paul morphy
and adolf anderson white sacrifices material at
every turn and finishes with a beautiful
beautiful checkmate the game opens up with e4
e5 and something original here on move 2 bishop
c4 the bishop's opening now the computer chess
championship games are played with an opening
book used to make the games more interesting so
the engines don't always play the most reliable
openings like the berlin they do discover new
territory so i'm not exactly sure when the engines
were out of book but it's usually the first two
or three moves so this definitely feels like
one of those moves now black plays bishop c5
and if they're not following book knight f6
would probably have been better than bishop c5
the problem with bishop c5 is that black
is copying white but why does it move ahead
and so white should be better equipped to
achieve c3 and d4 and attack and gain time
by harassing that bishop so after bishop c5 we
now see knight to f3 attacking the pawn here on e5
and now we see pawn to d6 white goes for the idea
i just mentioned pawn to c3 to step forward with
pawn to d4 and to attack that bishop and
build a great center with a gain of time
the next move is very unique to me queen to e7
i generally don't like having a queen on e7 but
of course when the bishop is no longer on f8 it's
much more reasonable however this move still seems
to work out very very badly for black but the only
way to take full advantage of this slight error is
really to sacrifice material which komodo shows
very very quickly that it is willing to do so
d4 is now very very natural and i wonder if one of
the reasons for queen e7 is maybe a miscalculation
from the engine it seems like queen e7 is kind
of designed to allow pawn takes d4 pawn takes d4
queen takes e4 check but this is a mistake queen
e7 has not stopped to break d4 because now after
king f1 black has problems the bishop is under
attack and if the bishop falls back there's the
nice move bishop takes f7 white is gaining a
huge advantage white did have to move the king
but now black also has to move the king and
white's gaining more tempos with moves like knight
c3 very very soon if the king captures the bishop
the problem is knight g5 check with a royal fork
winning the game so after pawn to d4 what we
actually see is the move bishop back to b6
right away and now knight g5 a common problem
beginning players know well the difficulties
that you can have when trying to defend this f7
pawn now black could play bishop e6 and accept
a weakened pawn structure but white is definitely
better there so black tries knight to h6 instead
after knight to h6 white goes ahead and castles
and we get knight to c6 putting pressure on the
pawn on d4 it is at this point in the game that
i really think komodo starts to show its stuff
we get the move pawn to a4 going for the move
pawn to a5 which will disrupt the coordination of
the minor pieces now of course black can capture
on d4 which is what scorpio goes ahead and does
and we do get a 5. tactically the only option
here is to capture with the bishop if you capture
with the knight white has the nice tactic
rook takes a5 bishop takes a5 and queen a4
check and a fork white is gaining material
and has a huge advantage in this position
notice that black also can't pull the bishop to c5
because the move pawn b4 would trap the bishop on
c5 so after a5 we do get bishop takes a5 and white
takes back on d4 and gains a beautiful center in
this position though black pulls back to b6 and
there's a big question what are you doing about
the pawn on d4 a natural developing move like
bishop e3 actually shows some of the problems
there is the move bishop takes d4 and black
is undermining the defense of this knight
in fact in this position scorpio is doing really
really well so instead after bishop to b6 we see
another sacrifice knight c3 in this game in
general komodo shows a total disdain for its pawns
it's always willing to give up pawns if it can
get piece activity so after knight to c3 we see
bishop takes d4 knight to d5 this is a beautiful
beautiful night it's definitely going to have
a huge role to play in this game the queen falls
back to d8 and i love the next move as well rook
to a3 an early rook left the rook is coming
over to the king side and it's going to be
very very potent now i think that the next move
is probably a mistake from scorpio i think it is
losing possibly better is the move bishop to g4
disrupting white's coordination and encouraging
the queen to move now white has a ton of activity
and probably an advantage after the move queen d2
but is white winning as in the game i don't
think so yet deep analysis by chess engines
does not indicate a clear win and at least after
the move played in the game which is castling i
can no longer find a defense so after rook to a3
we do get castles and now rook to g3 creating a
ton of latent threats now one thing to appreciate
in this position is just how darn difficult it is
to move anything for black the pieces don't look
to be so badly placed but they don't really have
targets or anything productive to do in the
position as a human the natural thing to do
seems to be to move this bishop out we want to
develop it but the developments lose tactically
for example after bishop e6 white can take on
e6 and after pawn takes e6 there is bishop takes
h6 this is a huge idea in the position the idea to
move the knight on g5 and then take the knight on
h6 now after capturing on h6 you may well notice
that there is a knight loose on d5 but after pawn
takes bishop takes d5 check white is winning for
example after king h8 we cannot take on g7 right
away and give mate because the square is defended
but we can play queen takes d4 making the first
of many queen sacrifices in this game after
queen takes d4 if the knight captures it as mate
but ultimately it is made in two after
anything that black tries so after bishop
takes d5 check more sensible is rook to f7 here
but there are many wins one win is bishop takes
king takes and then queen to b3 check king back
and then rook f3 check after bishop f6 queen e6
is really really pretty in this position the king
can't move at all really there's no productive
move and the idea of rook takes f6 basically wins
against anything that black tries another bishop
development to mention is the idea of bishop d7
when white can't move the knight by capturing
anything but you don't necessarily need to capture
when you move the knight to make big threats
in this position knight to f3 threatens knight
takes d4 and bishop takes h6 winning the game so
what we actually get is the move king to h8 a very
sad move to have to play when you're under attack
you're desperate to get your pieces into the game
so that they can contribute and when you have to
play moves like king h8 instead you feel like
you're really a sitting duck and your opponent
is just continuing to take cheap shots at your
chin so after the move king h8 we get queen h5
the queen is beautiful over on the h5 square the
bishop now does develop 2e6 and in this position
white has a crushing and beautiful move knight
takes h7 boom a strong and decisive knight
sacrifice now in this position because of the many
threats including bishop takes h6 there is really
no alternative to accepting the knight's sacrifice
king takes h7 now in this position the idea is
either to play bishop d3 or e5 and both moves are
part of a decisive attack obviously the bishop is
participating in the attack but also the e5 brake
will close off this bishop's ability to defend g7
that's important because if the bishop is not
defending g7 we can often sacrifice our rook
and force mate or the win of material so it's
hard to decide between the moves e5 and bishop d3
but deeper calculation that you can check in
the notes shows that komodo's bishop d3 is the
better move after bishop d3 in this position one
idea might be knight to e5 to stop the e5 break
and to attack this bishop down here but in
this position we've blocked the bishop on d4
so it's time to sacrifice the rook rook takes g7
king takes and queen takes h6 now in this position
after king g8 knight to f6 check there's no way
to get out of check other than giving up the queen
and after queen takes f6 you can't capture on
d3 because your own bishop hangs so white is up
too much material and white wins the game fairly
easily in the game we see a better defensive try
it is the move rook to h8 now in this position i
think most humans would want to go for the move
e5 check but this move is a big mistake there is
king g8 bishop takes h6 and then bishop takes e5
in this position you did win the knight on h6 but
you're already down at night so you're still down
material and you're in trouble in h6 you're
in trouble on d5 and you are in trouble on g3
in fact there is a draw here but i'm not
going to tell you what it is because the
idea is going to come up again in the game but
with a little twist that makes it a winning idea
so what's actually played after rook to h8 is
the move bishop to g5 awkwardly attacking the
black queen so that queen moves over to c8
now one alternative idea instead of queen c8
is the move g6 this is a clever idea because
if you capture the knight then after king g8
your own queen is trapped and although you
can trade queens by capturing black's queen
it's not so easy to win the game but after g6
we can play e5 pinning this pawn so it can't
capture and now black has too many problems on h6
and on d8 white's attack should be decisive here
so after bishop g5 we did get that move queen
c8 and now e5 check king g8 bishop takes h6
bishop takes e5 and this is very very similar to
the position we just looked at where i said that
white could not win the game however there's a
difference black's queen has had to move and so
now white has a forced winning continuation if you
want to play like komodo pause your video and find
the only decisive way the winning move here is
queen takes e5 boom a tremendous and immediately
decisive move again this feels straight out of
the 1800s straight out of paul morphy's and adolf
anderson's handbook now there's no alternative
to accepting the queen sacrifice because
white still has a huge attack in this position so
pawn takes e5 rook takes g7 check and king over to
f8 but still in this position what does white have
as a follow-up it's another sacrifice rook to g8
and double check because it's double check check
from both the bishop and the rook here it's not
possible to capture the rook with the rook instead
only the king can capture and in this position
there is knight to f6 and check mate it's a good
thing the queen is no longer on the d8 square
this is a beautiful checkmate i hope you've
enjoyed this whole game but certainly the finish
with queen takes e5 punch number one and then
rook takes g7 and rook to g8 punch number two
and finally knight to f6 the knockout blow
is just a dazzling dazzling idea and i hope
you enjoyed it as much as i do i hope you also
found it to be the best chess miniature that has
existed in this century if you want to check out
more really beautiful often more sophisticated
computer chess games then definitely click on
the playlist that is popping up on your screen